THAT REALLY HARD.
MEANWHILE, THE EUROPEAN UNION IS
CONSIDERING A NEW TRAVEL BAN ON
AMERICA.
A BAN ON AMERICAN’S TRAVELING TO
EUROPE IN RESPONSE TO
CORONAVIRUS CASES.
DR. MARC SIEGEL JOINS US WITH
THE LATEST ON THIS.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> HI, TUCKER.
LET’S TAKE THIS BACK TO
MARCH 11TH WHEN ITALY PASSED
10,000 CASES AND IN THE
UNITED STATES HERE, WE HAD 1100
CONFIRMED CASES.
ISSUED THAT TRAVEL BAN WERE
BASICALLY SAID 26 COUNTRIES
STRETCHING FROM ICELAND TO
GREECE, COULDN’T TRAVEL TO HERE
FROM EUROPE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT THE
EUROPEAN UNION DID?
THEY WERE HORRIFIED.
THEY CALLED PRESIDENT TRUMP
IRRESPONSIBLE.
BUT LOOKING BACKWARD, WE SEE
THAT MOST OF OUR CASES AT LEAST
ON THE EAST COAST CAME HERE FROM
EUROPE BECAUSE THEY WERE
RECEIVING CASES FROM CHINA AND
THEN ON INTO THE UNITED STATES.
LOOK TODAY AT JUNE 23RD WHERE
ITALY HAS ONE-TENTH OF THAT.
NOW THE EUROPEAN UNION IS
GETTING READY TO REOPEN THEIR
BORDERS.
GUESS WHO MAY NOT BE ON THE
LIST?
THE UNITED STATES.
GUESS WHO IS ON THE LIST?
CHINA.
AND THE EUROPEAN UNION IS
CALLING OUR HANDLING OF THE
CORONAVIRUS OF FAILURE.
WELL, MAYBE IT’S A FAILURE
BECAUSE WHEN WE THOUGHT WE HAD
1100 CASES, WE PROBABLY HAD OVER
A MILLION OR AT LEAST SEVERAL
HUNDRED THOUSAND BY THAT POINT.
NOW, YOU CAN MAKE A CASE OF THIS
BEING PUBLIC HEALTH ON THE PART
OF THE EUROPEAN UNION.
THEY ARE SAYING IF YOU LIVE IN A
STATE OR REGION WHERE THERE IS
LESS THAN 50 CASES FOR 100,000
PEOPLE, TRAVELING TO THE
EUROPEAN UNION, YOU CAN TRAVEL
TO EUROPE.
MONTANA, SOUTH DAKOTA, WYOMING,
YOU ARE IN.
NEW YORK, TEXAS, ARIZONA, YOU
WERE OUT.
SO I THINK THIS WILL HAVE A HUGE
IMPACT ON YOUR ECONOMY AND
WONDERING IF THIS COULD HAVE
SOMETHING TO DO WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP THIS WEEK SAYING
THAT FOREIGN WORKERS VISAS ARE
NOT ALLOWED INTO THE COUNTRY.
WHATEVER IT IS, IT IS NOT THE
SOUND IS SOUNDED BACK IN MARCH.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF CASES
WERE COMING HERE, SO I HAVE A
MESSAGE FOR THE EUROPEAN UNION
TONIGHT.
HOW ABOUT REMEMBERING WE ARE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE 20TH CENTURY?
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT’S
WORTH REMINDING.
GLOBAL POWER POLITICS AT WORK AS
ALWAYS UNDER THE MASQUERADE OF